Great job.
Let's review what we've
done in this lesson.
First, we made an interactive
prototype using InVision.
Second, we changed it in reaction
to our first round of feedback.
Next, we shared it with subject
matter experts and users.
Finally, we got feedback using
our interactive prototype.
>> In the next lesson, we'll talk
about how to bring your prototype to
an engineer to think
about getting it built.
We'll also talk about how to continue to
iterate your prototype through the rest
of the process.
Finally, we'll talk about
using your app prototype
to talk about your app with investors or
other people interested.
See you in Lesson Three.